Again, the areas in black are the total area covered, which we obtained from the mission,
and the areas in red are the pieces which we missed due to the deletion of the plane change,
and the early return.
This little piece down here was a blight pass, which we had planned with the pen camera.
It would have taken place on Grab 72 in order to get photographs of the ascending,
which is an area in particular interesting to the geology.
So you can see that we did lose some data.
On the other hand, we did pick up some data that we would not have gotten,
and I think overall the effectiveness of the pen of the coverage was about 90%
of what we had hoped for pre-mission.
I really want to express the thanks of the photo team to the flight planners here,
and also to Ken for his operation of the cameras during the mission.
I know that it was very confusing to be continually changing the flight plan,
and Ken probably wondered what the hell we were doing with all these odd options, so on.
But really, I think we did a very effective job of recovering almost all of the data that we had planned for the mission.
I have the next slide, please.
This is a diagram showing what the Apollo 15 coverage was like.
This is a plan coverage for the 16 mission, and in the dotted line is a plan coverage for the 17 mission.
The only reason I show this is to indicate that the areas where we did lose data,
unfortunately, are in the areas that were not covered by 15 and will not be covered by 17,
so that the losses, although small, were real.
We have the next slide.
Ken, during the film recovery EVA, you reported that the stellar camera glare shield was hung up on the handrail.
I'm not 100% clear as to exactly what that situation was.
This is the stellar camera glare shield, and this is a little cover that comes down and covers that when the mapping camera is retracted.
Now, maybe you've discussed this with the other people here at the center, but for my own information,
I would like to know whether this is the cover that was hung up or this is covered.
Both of the shield at the forward end, that one.
This one?
No.
The first one you looked at, yeah.
That was sticking up.
That is sticking up.
Yeah.
But the tip out here was matched against the handrail.
Mashed against the handrail out in the front here.
The rail in this picture.
The rail is not installed a bit along here.
That's right.
This lip was up against it and bent back out of the way.
Oh, I see.
That was not in a full extent position.
Look, I have a partial extension.
Uh-huh.
Could you tell whether this was bent, whether this rail was bent, which is extend rail?
No, but I think we are full of the probably telling that.
I don't remember.
The end of the shield was bent, whether that rail, no.
Yeah.
In the next section of the collection, that one was bent.
Now, whether that rail itself was bent, I didn't notice.
Uh-huh.
The implication, of course, is that if this had happened early in the mission and this
shield were bent down, we might get excessive light into the stellar camera and our background
density would be low or would be higher than we expected.
We might not see as many stars.
The other indication of malfunction that we had, of course, was in the exposure control
on the pan camera.
And that would indicate that the pictures away from the terminal may be overexposed.
That situation is also being looked at.
And again, we're going to talk about it this afternoon before we actually process the film.
Uh-huh.
The next slide.
This is the information which I have with regard to the laser altimeter operation.
Uh-huh.
The first row across here is what the nominal mission would have been.
And the second row is the actual results from the Apollo 16.
Uh-huh.
We had planned a total of 20 hours and a few minutes of operating time.
We got 14 hours and a half so that we are down about 25 percent in the total operating
time.
This is the total revolutions in longitude that we had planned 10.3 and we got seven and a half.
So again, we're down about 25 percent in that regard.
Uh-huh.
A total number of firings, 3283 and 2106 is the actual number that was recorded.
So we are down nearly 30 percent in the total number of firings.
Also, the number of valid elevation readings that we got was appreciably less than the
total number of firings so that we, the actual mission in terms of altimeter observations
gave us a little bit less than half of what we had actually planned.
Uh-huh.
That's really not as serious a short fall as it sounds just from the numbers because the
readings were quite well distributed throughout the mission.
Uh-huh.
The general operation that we saw on the altimeter, uh-huh, the first several railroads were
completely nominal.
All of the elevation readings were valid.
Then it began to fall off about 75 percent, 65 percent and down to about 60 percent except
on the last data pass on Route 62 where it was only about, uh-huh, 10 percent effective.
Generally what we seem to observe is that there would be one good shot and one bad shot
and one good one bad and then maybe several good ones in a row.
Uh-huh.
We can talk about the reason for that but, uh-huh, that's more appropriately covered in these
systems review tomorrow.
Uh-huh.
The effect that it will have on the data is simply to give us a, a larger spacing between
data points.
So far as the, it's effect on the reduction of the photography is concerned that's absolutely
inconsequential.
So far as it's effect on the, uh, correlation between the tracking and gravity data and
the, uh, profiles, it's a little bit, uh, more of concern.
Uh-huh.
They do have a little bit more smoothing to do between the data points that they got but
essentially I don't think that it really hurts us so far as the scientific return, uh,
from the mission is concerned.
Uh-huh.
I would like to say of just a word or so about the utilization of the photography, the,
it has been proceeding much more slowly than I had anticipated in reducing the pictures
from Apollo 15.
However, the work which is being done by the ACIC and St. Louis is indicating that the
photography, photographic reduction will provide, uh, positional coordinates of features
on the lunar surface with the, uh, the accuracy of 10 to 12 meters in position and in elevation.
And that seems to coincide very well with what we had predicted premission.
So, uh, we are quite confident that, uh, that we're getting very good information from
the pictures in that regard.
The tracking data, uh, generally, uh, is consistent within an orbital pass but we do find
uh, discrepancies of, uh, up to a kilometer between adjacent photographic passes so that
the, uh, reduction of the photographs is giving us a much better tie between orbital, uh,
passes than we get from the, from the tracking data, uh, itself.
Consequently, we do expect eventually to come up with a, an internally consistent coordinate
system reference system figure of the moon with an accuracy on the order of 12 to 15 meters.
Uh, that's, uh, highly gratifying to me.
Um, so far as the pan camera utilization is concerned, there have been some, uh, map
compilations done, uh, the indicated precision of those is on the order of three meters,
which again is about what we had expected, but that is a precision and not an accuracy
number because, uh, the geometric problems with the pan camera photography.
However, so far as the resolution of the pan camera is concerned, that has held up to just
about what we had expected, uh, from one and a half to three meters at the, uh, sub
vehicle point and decreasing off to about five to six meters at the limits of the, of the
film.
Uh, so, so far as, uh, our indications at the moment are that the results from 16 are quite
satisfactory.
We do have these problems that we have to resolve and the processing of the film.
And, uh, once that is done, we will be able to say exactly what we did obtain.
But again, I want to express the photo team's thanks to you, particularly Ken for the, uh,
uh, time and attention, uh, that you gave to the camera operation and the results that
we have obtained.
Thanks.
Got any questions, uh, for?
Could you, do you have a plot of the, uh, altimetry, you know, last time someone had
drawn up a rough, hand sketch of, of the altimetry, you know, did anyone do that this
time?
Uh, no, I don't can.
I think maybe, uh, children has one of those, uh, and, uh, you know, it's either, yeah,
Bill.
Yeah, Bill.
Yeah.
Do you have a plot?
Yeah, I thought you had one.
These are particles that you found in the mapping camera that, is that handfuls or, or a couple
of, uh, savings or, uh, I don't know how extensive they, uh, they were, uh, they were
enough to concern the, uh, uh, the people in the processing lab, uh, all I know, that's
about all that I know about it, we're supposed to have a review of that this afternoon.
It could have, uh, very serious implications, obviously, uh, one, one thing that I seem to
recall from the, uh, during the mission is that we had apparently more film left for post
T.E.I. photography than we had anticipated.
And what that could mean, of course, is that the, the camera was not passing film when
we thought it was and things were being chewed up pretty badly inside.
So, uh, we're going to have to look that over very carefully before we go ahead
with the processing of the film.
We expect the, uh, camera contractor to, uh, look at the shavings and tell us where
he thinks they came from and that may give us a better clue as to what they are actually
are.
Do you have a processing schedule yet?
I guess it's all in advance to what they do and hold until this afternoon, you know,
after we're, uh, meeting this afternoon, we're assuming you determine to go ahead and develop
a little take you three, four days to process.
Yeah.
Uh, I think the, the anticipated schedule was to have, uh, the original film processed
within this week and all of the duplicate copies within four weeks of distributed.
Perhaps you explained it into one of the accuracy of the alternative.
The, uh, least count of the altimeter is, uh, one meter.
The accuracy is, uh, dependent, uh, pretty much upon the slope in the area which is illuminated
and, uh, the little bit, uh, on the albedo in the area which is illuminated.
In general, I think it's fair to say that, uh, the reading that we get from the altimeter
will be correct, uh, two within three to five meters.
Hey, have you figured out what to do with the pan camera for processing?
Okay.
Got a correction for the, for the exposure?
Uh, I don't know what has been figured out.
We had a group working on it last week and they're going to give us a report right after
this meeting.
It's like what to do.
Yeah.
I could, I mean, um, when I was made a recommendation, you know, to work back first
things, and, uh, they think that the movies, um, white-offs will generate anything to do
that.
Uh, you know, that they can't handle the other things, but that's some penalty where
we have to work right.
The situation is really that, uh, near the terminator, the pictures are underexposed
anyhow, because we can't open the slick widen up and so on.
Uh, so the camera was wide open at the terminator, uh, but it was open wider than it should
have been when we were away from the terminator, so that the terminator pictures are a little
bit underexposed.
Then they become properly exposed and after that, uh, they will be overexposed.
So what we would really like, of course, is a variable, uh, processing, uh, through each
photo pass, but that's probably not the feasible thing to even contemplate.
Thanks, Fred.
Nice subject to it will be the particles and fields of the subset of light, and, uh, I think
what I'm going to call it is going to cover that is see here.
Yeah.
Oh, there he is.
We got a mic right up there.
Yeah, they'll, they'll project it up there in the back booth if you want to.
That deck, where's where's ball?
Which, which could you get this projected up there?
Okay, can you hear me okay on?
Okay.
I guess, uh, quickly the subset of light was the void successfully.
Our spin rate was nominal about five and a second spin period.
We want five plus or minus a couple.
Well, the attitude was good, uh, according to preliminary indications on sensor.
We're, have a couple of degrees, uh, kept off from the ecliptic, which as well within
the limits we needed.
The operation of all of the, uh, electric static analyzers and both solid state telescopes
is good.
Uh, we don't seem to have the noise problem that we had on Apollo 15 and a couple of
analyzers.
And we've, we've got a bit of our accumulator counting errors.
I'd be here for characteristics of 15.
I'm just giving us some problems in our data analysis now on that satellite.
Oh, okay.
The quick look, uh, results on our first minute of tail pass and hit again the, uh,
in the presence of these rather, uh, you know, expected rather high, uh,
fluxes of low energy protons, which have also been seen now with a new,
um, series I satellite experiment too.
And on this minute of tail pass, we appear to have the, uh, remnants of a small solar
event of the form of some high energy solar cosmic ray electrons and protons around,
which, uh, should prove, uh, interesting for our shadow interpretation,
particularly on electric fields in the magneto tail.
You know, on that, if they have those slides there, I'd like to briefly describe, uh,
some of the results we got from Apollo 15 would hope to be similar for this one.
Uh, our primary, uh, experiment was to examine particle shadow configurations in the magneto tail,
uh, to be while we're passing through this region back here where we are in the Earth's magnetic field.
And, uh, use that to examine the, uh, question of openness and access through the magneto tail to the magnetic field lines,
and ultimately to the man Allen belts, where, uh,
theory generally holds that, uh, the bound radiation must somehow come in and then be trapped and accelerated.
The degree of connection back here with the interplanetary field has been in quite a bit of question,
and briefly stated the Apollo 15 results indicate pretty clearly that at least most of the time,
at the, uh, latitudes where we pass through the tail, of course we only have a couple of passes,
that, uh, these, uh, field lines are, in fact, open out here, connect directly into the interplanetary field,
and have direct access of solar cosmic ray particles.
We have also observed, uh, the existence of a, uh, plasma sheet, which is known to form in closer to the Earth,
to extend out to them in the distance.
And, uh, at least a couple of occasions we have observed, uh, cross tail electric fields,
which are important to theoretical models, uh, accounting for Aurora,
and for solaration particles into the radiation belts.
Uh, unexpected observation, which, uh, we found interesting was 30KV,
or thereabouts protons in very large numbers, which we observed quite frequently back in the magnitude of tail,
and also those are outside in magnitude of tail, in very similar fluxes.
Our, uh, first feeling was that these must also be some, uh,
component of the, uh, solar cosmic ray proton spectrum.
Their, of course, very low energy would be stopped by even the thinnest piece of material,
but the, uh, numbers of them, and the consistency of their flux density is making them,
uh, very attractive as, probably being indicative, quite indicative of, uh, the source that they come from,
and mechanism, bringing them.
Uh, further examination, however, of the locations where we see them,
and of the almost, uh, constant intensities that we see,
uh, almost, for us, the conclusions that they must somehow,
the protons from the, uh, outer van Allen belt region here,
which are somehow, uh, coming loose from the Earth's field,
and moving outward, and then getting on to the interplanetary fields,
and then moving out to where we see them, and, uh, perhaps at any inverse process of the postulated, uh,
process where we bring, uh, solar cosmic ray particles in from the sun to populate the van Allen belts initially.
Uh, we're actually, uh, waiting, getting our data,
and now our computer programs that, uh, berkeley and shape where we can examine this in detail,
and if unfortunately we've been delayed in that.
If I have the next slide, I'll show you one orbit of data from the telescopes,
when these, uh, very, uh, steady fluxes of protons were present,
and, uh, during this period, and actually for a period of, uh, a couple of orbits,
earlier, these fluxes were almost constant.
There is some, uh, changing here.
There, there, there is a very, very slight shadowing of protons, not very much at all.
This is most in electron phenomena, but then these particles essentially turn off,
as if somebody closed a valve, and this is characteristic of the way they behave.
When they appear, they're suddenly there, and when they disappear, they're gone just as fast.
And, uh, we're very hopeful that we'll be able to make some sense out of what turns these things on and off,
and determine what, where they're coming from, and what the mechanism is,
and presumably now in the magnetosphere.
Okay, I think I'll just throw it open to any questions, so I'll now.
Okay.
Where's the lifetime estimate of the 16?
All right.
Next speaker.
I wish you hadn't brought that up for the home's getting very short.
Next speaker, get that force.
We had been very hopeful of getting another dozen, or a couple of dozen,
my eukail passes out of the satellite since it worked so beautifully.
I think we're going to go over there.
First said it was going to stay up there forever, so it better.
Okay.
The world's going to come to a very short layover.
Any other questions about particles and fuels?
Okay.
Let's continue on with subset of light and get on the planet.
No, we didn't say anything about it.
I assume that our satellite is sending out good data.
Is battery charging okay and everything?
It's not running into the problem with the 15 guys' hand, or was that normal for the...
The machine is working.
And all the detectors are operating.
No, no, no.
It's just that it's going to short lay time.
Okay.
Let's see.
I think Larry Sharp is going to take...
Call this place, right?
Okay.
Right at the top of it.
The objectives of magnetometer is going to essentially pre-pull,
first is to measure and map the remnant magnetism on the lunar surface,
second is to map the electrical conductivity of the lunar interior,
finally studying the various aspects of moon's interaction with the fields of particles
and its environment.
The wise scope of these objectives is made possible by the geometries and the sort of
this passes through the three fundamentally different regions of space.
For example, to get the spatial variations of remnant magnetism on the lunar surface,
one must be in a geomagnetic tail where the temporal variations are almost absent
in the magnetic field, very steady situation.
The initial orbit of the sub-satellite was somewhat lower than Apollo 15,
and the inclination of about 11 degrees instead of 28.
And I'd like to show you the predictions in orbit.
Okay, we've plotted days past deployment,
versus the parallel altitude.
Okay, we've plotted days past deployment versus the parallel altitude.
Okay, we started out here in pretty good shape.
About 97 kilometers or 97 by 123, I guess.
And the prediction was a very rapid drop down to 30 some.
Back up in good shape.
No real trouble until it's the ground line.
Tell about 200 days when the probability is 50, 50 of a crash.
Here's the error bars here.
You can say the probability was only one chance in 10 of a crash here,
and maybe one chance in five.
We've updated this plot.
And the odds have changed considerably.
This was the prediction.
Notice the time scale has been expanded.
Greatly, these are hours now instead of days.
Here was the initial prediction at 37 kilometers
in here, the actual data points.
This one has taken this morning, around in here.
And if you can extrapolate by eye,
it looks like we have about four days left.
I guess Bill Sogren's taking 50-50 odds that it will crash.
If anyone's in a betting boot.
It's possible that we'll skim the surface and come back out.
Even if we make it through this one,
that next dip is going to probably finish this off.
Which is most unfortunate.
It might be out of your field,
but I'll cut my prediction.
Didn't match the actual value.
I mean, we saw it.
You got to go grab your spare.
We got another grab, you feel that well.
And that's the minimum of this satellite.
You're here at Philadelphia.
Right.
Okay.
And now we're going to stream like it about these pads.
And I'll go along up here in the sea and try to drive that point
on so many times.
I think we're really seeing a couple of them.
Just goes to show you can't redo six months of planning in two days.
Well, any event, we have one month's worth of good data,
which we'll add to our Apollo 15 results.
And to get some idea of what we're doing with this data,
I'd like to show the first slide,
which represents an average of 17 different orbits,
taken when the moon was in the Earth's magneto tail.
And we've plotted moon's longitude along the horizontal.
And the magnetic field in gamma's along the vertical.
These numbers are representative of the Earth's tail field.
And of course, if you subtract out an average value,
this residual would represent the lunar surface field.
And of course, the big result is this really huge magnetic dip
going over the landing graph crater,
or region right near the landing graph crater.
Also, the other initial result we got out of 15 data
was that most of the dips in the magnetic field
seem to be clearly associated with craters,
lined with a few degrees of the ground track
to find by the orbit sub-satellite.
We've numbered the seven most obvious local minimum,
named five of them with associated craters.
Our initial results from Apollo 16 show
the same type of structure,
although we don't see anything as big as the landing graph.
We see we do go over corollove again.
That's where the orbit intersect when we're in the tail.
And we see a few other Hertz-Brung and Pavlov type bumps.
One is with a little tiny crater called Stein.
And one near Mendeleff.
If you do repeat this procedure several times with different
new nations, so you cover different tracks over the moon.
And this allows a contour map to be made.
So if I go to the next slide,
I'll just show the ground track from where we
found the island.
Here's one over Hertz-Brung, corollove.
Here's the landing graph.
You can see right close to the northern border,
Pavlov, and one over Mill.
Those are pretty good one-to-one correspondence
with large craters.
The initial 11 orbit, of course,
is much near the equator.
The inclination goes up to plus and minus 11.
So we saw one over corollove, and Stein
craters located right about here.
It's not too big.
The next map shows a compilation of a lot of these linear
profiles.
Next slide, into a contour map.
A little harder to read the contours.
You can see this big black blotch here is a result of
contours stacked on top of each other near this
landing graph anomaly.
You can see the numbers are hard to make out.
You can see this structure over corollove.
A hint of some structure over Hertz-Brung.
And the southern sea over here is actually an
enhancement sticking out of the moon, so to speak.
You can see Mill and shows a definite structure.
Now the Powell 16 results should
enable us to expand this map.
We'll get better resolutions throughout this area,
and be able to extend it along in here.
We'll probably still have a gap down in this region.
The numbers presented in the chart, if you can see them,
are measured in tenths of gamma at altitude of 100
kilometers.
So for example, a good representative values about 30,
and the zero we've arbitrarily chosen at the bottom
of the landing graph dip, since this is the lowest value
of magnitude as we observe, you just call it zero
and scale everything relative to it.
So if you're at 100 kilometers, you'll see a 3-game
of dip going over the landing graph on the average.
Oh, you're fortunate.
Also, the near side of the moon, if not.
Does the gravity profile of any current can you correlate?
I've looked at the gravity profile, and it doesn't seem
to correlate at all.
Actually, the laser data correlates better with...
There's no gravity in the backside.
Okay, I'm on the side.
Interesting.
The correlate is pretty well with the laser data,
which shows great big hole here in the backside of the moon
around the landing graph.
That's what we get our big hole, but I can't see any scientific
justification for connecting it to results.
I will add to this reminded the gamma ray.
Yes, that's true.
Because also a band of gravity.
I don't know what it means.
It could be an alien star base or something.
Anyway, the next slide shows the front side of the moon.
And it's upside down.
The thing to contrast is the much smoother nature.
Could we do a 180 on the slide, please?
Can you hear me?
Could we turn the slide around, please?
Oh, he's on a coffee break.
Okay, here.
Anyway, the front side of the moon is much, much
smooth in the backside.
The variations are, oh, on order of a factor of 10,
smooth.
We don't see very much structure at all.
It's very hard to even draw contours.
Can you sort out the differences in that and the effects of running
through the Earth's magnetic field effects,
since the front side is always close to the Earth.
Can you sort out?
Are we really measuring magnetic variations on the backside
caused by being on the backside, not due to our measuring
environment?
All right, the Earth's tail field.
It's very, very constant when you're in need of it.
Good second.
When you're away from the neutral sheet.
And that's where all this data is taken.
Well, I guess we never got the front.
It's like complete.
Okay, this is a blow-up of the Van de Graf region,
an attempt to pinpoint the exact source of this large anomaly.
We kind of suspected it was over the crater itself,
since we had always put forth a theory that what we were
actually observing in these dips was some sort of a meteorite
impact that caused a rather uniforming magnetized crust
to suddenly have holes in it, and we're seeing the equivalent
dipole of what was left over.
And this kind of shoots holes in the theory.
We see this is the BX component, which is the radio component,
and a plus number indicates a value sticking in the moon.
We see this rather large hole here magnetically in between two
craters.
And if you look at various models of double dipoles and stuff,
it just doesn't quite fit.
The other components, BX, BX, show that it can't be one of
these angling dipoles from the crater.
And presently, we're now conducting the same sort of studies
over the rest of the anomaly.
It's just yesterday completed the one over Corlev,
and that one is right in the middle of the crater,
which is promising for this chalky magnetization theory.
How much do we have in the contract need at the benefit of the
plus sign?
How much fluid is it?
How much fluid do we have in the ephemeris?
I understand there's no chance that we could be off by a longer
two.
The longer it did.
So it doesn't seem much chance.
Well, maybe one more is the subset, like, comes crashing down
in the moon.
The last 10 kilometers should give us a good swath of data,
which will give us another high resolution plot like this.
Other than that, we're kind of lucky.
OK.
Let me go.
OK, thank you.
Question?
OK.
There's the front side of the moon.
OK, and our coverage from Apollo 11 will extend.
Yeah, I believe this is equated across here.
Oh, I'm sorry.
OK, this is zero degrees.
OK, I'm going from zero to 90 east to 90 west.
It's the terminator.
This is southern sea region, which is about the only distinctive
feature on the front side per se, and even that's on the
terminator.
And again, these are relatively high values of magnetic fields
sticking out of the moon.
So you might say that the southern sea is a highly magnetized
region.
Notice the 16-side is out of our coverage as we're all
the Apollo landing sites.
Yeah, that's three games.
Well, most of these values are about 38, 28, 27, which means
they're all three gamma hired in a zero at bandi graph.
So the maximum plus or minus is about a half a gamma, and
the whole front side.
So why do you're not at least the elongate parallel
to the track?
This is a function of not having quite enough data.
Instead of making physical looking contours, we drew
actual contours with the data.
And obviously, there's a little bit of offset from one
orbit to the next.
It's going to result in elongated contours.
If we fixed this up, we're in mates and intelligent
looking guesses.
They would be much more circular.
Here at Asia, on the Apollo 12 and the 15 and the 16
surface of the data.
Yes, with 12, 14, 15.
Yes.
Well, how do you call it with the information of the data?
Well, you see the surface data is deals with what's smaller
scales size phenomena.
And so there's really no one-to-one correlation.
I suppose that the...
Well, I think it'd be sure that over a region of 100
kilometers at the average field was 38 gamma,
which no one would bet on.
Then we could make some interesting predictions
about other places on the moon.
But I suspect if you went down to Apollo 12 and went 100
meters away, you'd find a much different value
in the magnetic field.
We noticed the case, look at Apollo 14.
They went one kilometer and they went from 43 gamma
to 103 gamma.
So who's to say what's a representative value
for the magnetic field in the given area?
Apollo 15.
Apollo 15, they saw a steady field of 6 plus or minus
4 gamma, which is essentially 0.
But there again, you know, behind the next boulder,
it would be 100 gamma, probably.
And the results in 16, I thought we were tremendous.
Menus gradients, they got between one place and another.
At 313 gamma field, it would be surprised me,
as far as getting value at large.
Yes?
No?
No.
I'm not a geologist tape.
That would change.
It would seem to me that the younger a crater was,
a more chance it would have to produce a good clean
cut signature on the magnetic field data.
For example, Van de Graff itself looks like a fairly young
crater because there's very few secondary
craters in the bottom of it.
So it looks fairly young, where things like
hertz run seem to be very old.
They're well-blashed for secondary craters.
Well, this is good.
I'm not a member of Van de Graff.
It's 80 kilometers from the northern rim.
So from the center of Van de Graff,
it's about 130 or 40 kilometers.
Any other questions?
Okay, thank you, Larry.
Last subject, we'll be the transponder.
Oh, this is the gravity experiment.
And we monitor the gravity by just monitoring the
velocity of the spacecraft, or the lab,
or the sub-satellite.
Of course, on this particular mission, we lost our
limb data on impact because it started crumbling.
And so that data was lost.
We do have the CSM in the low altitude orbit,
which is very interesting data.
Here is the orbital track.
And hopefully, I can get this aligned.
Not like this.
This profile just below it is the gravity anomaly
that was detected.
This line right here represents zero gravity center.
I just got to get equilibrium.
And anything below it, of course,
would be negative gravity deviations.
Here we are at Tolomeus,
going essentially over the center with the track.
And we can see the large negative anomaly.
Again, almost 100 milligales.
Here we see some highland material,
where we have a positive.
Then we drop that into a relative low
in between these two old craters,
the park is now the technius.
And then a high in here.
At this point, this is the day cart,
the landing site, and we're actually at about a 50 milligale
negative anomaly in that region.
There's some nice correlations here with the
laser altimetry measurements.
I'll show them in the next profile.
But this is continuous.
I've just taken one small section here.
We have this thing from limb to limb.
So about 110 longitude plus to 110 minus.
And essentially, three revs and revs three through rev.
11, eight revs.
Eight revs of data that are pretty good.
And then they started their station keeping
in a data kind of garbage stuff a lot.
All of the new things going on.
I don't even plan out one kind of interesting thing here.
Notice that Tylenase here has an anomaly much lower
than Nubium.
I'll note Nubium, which is this region right in here,
this marinubium right in here.
It's still at about minus 50 milligales.
Here's an altimeter profile.
And going right to the Nubium Tylenase region again,
we see that Nubium elevation here is some,
by the way, the scale here is two kilometers
per heavy line.
So we've dropped down here almost two kilometers
from the floor of Tylenase to the floor of Nubium.
Yet the gravity anomaly is just the opposite
that Tylenase is some 50 milligales lower
than the Nubium region.
And another interesting point is,
Fred on these ACIC maps, Nubium is showing
a kilometer higher than Tylenase.
And here we are, two kilometers lower.
So we're talking about three kilometers of scrapancy
in just that little area right there.
So I think some of these guys were talking about the right thing
when they said we really didn't know the altitudes.
I think that shows up quite dramatically
when you look at the low sun angle view
as you approach the terminator, the things that were in Nubium
didn't show up until significantly after we anticipated.
We missed our times on those things, a great deal.
And I could only be called by having a discrepancy
in our relative heights.
Yeah, this is not just, this is red 28.
We've looked at, there are five real good tracking,
laser tracking passes over this region.
And we've looked at three of them.
And all three show the same consistency of the drop there.
Other interesting thing here, Prokalarm,
Tranquilatatus, Fricundatatus,
are all seem to be about on the same level.
Smithy I, again, being below about four and a half
kilometers, that was the same thing on the Apollo 15
when we passed over it.
It was some four and a half kilometers below,
as mean radius here.
And we're still referencing this to a 1738,
well, 0.1 radius off the CG.
If you take this stuff and start fitting it
to an optical center with a CG offset
that you do indeed get the two kilometers shift again
of the CG being closer to the Earth by some two kilometers.
Let's say that Tranquilatatus is about two and a half kilometers
lower than the car.
That's right.
Yeah, here's the landing site right in here.
And this is where we had a negative gravity anomaly in here.
Well, kind of according to this name,
this situation, because it looks like a topographic load.
This is the backside.
We had some, these are the limbs where the data was missing.
These are taken from those data taken from that thrift printout
that we get in real time.
And there's gaps in the data.
These will be filled in once they get the station tapes delivered.
Or we can see the crater hurt sprung here very evidently
with the central peak or something in it.
You don't have any data in that 120 degree region.
Not now, which we should have next week or so.
I'm going to get the tapes here.
One of the things that, well, on Apollo 15,
there is a definite, well, centered about 180.
There was a definite big trough in here.
We went down about some four and a half kilometers.
It was very jagged.
But it was centered just about here.
On Apollo 16, now we do not really see that.
We see this highland material here, which we had on 15.
That started about in here and showed a marked high region in there.
And this is holding on 16 also.
So this is kind of consistent with 15.
Here's another, this is orbit 38 on the backside.
I'm just kind of lay it there to show you some of the consistency.
This is 10 orbits later.
The profile is almost there.
Smith, the eye.
Oh, here we have some data in that.
So there is some there is your data.
10.
Well, you're looking for some particular feature right there.
You're looking for something around 105.
105.
I do have some data on the sub satellite from Apollo 15.
But I don't know if that's the time to really show you.
I think I've shown enough stuff on 16.
Yeah.
Well, I like to stick to 16.
Any of the problems we have or any of the data that we got for the group.
Well, I'm very happy with all the data we've gotten on 16.
And sub satellite on 16, like Larry mentioned just before me.
It's pretty grim.
Although there wasn't no D solution just run out about an hour ago,
where the last state vector was used as the position for running out the lifetime program.
If we believe that 15-8 model that we had used initially back there when we
objected that thing, says if this thing should come back up.
Still says it's not going to crash.
But this would be a very interesting thing to watch the next couple days.
Right.
That's the right thing to hold this as long as I'm upgraded.
Well, it's just...
I had to talk about that.
And I don't know where he can speak for later or not.
But I told him it's 50 pounds and where they can actually see it in fact of 50 pounds.
I think that's all the way to the central station.
Oh, that should hit about maybe some 20 or 30 degrees,
west line to two, then five or six degrees north.
That right thing, something like that.
Five or six, no, that's latitude, and about 30 west.
That's what it looks like in a...
That linear extrapolation.
Okay.
That's reasonable.
Well, thank you, Bill.
Thank you, gentlemen, for attending.
This concludes our scientific debrief.
And I'd like to thank the crew for giving their time up to come on over to.
Give us some information and also learn some things that will happen.
Okay.
Let me say something for the crew.
I want to commend Ken for the way that he operated the Sim Bay.
I don't think you'll ever find a guy who's either more interested in it or more aware of what the operational problems were and who could do a better job.
He really did an outstanding job and I think he's well done.
The other thing I'd like to say is, since I've been on this program,
I've been continually impressed with the importance of what we're doing in our support of you guys.
These experiments, they look way out right now and they're difficult for the man in the street to relate to.
But my feeling is from some of the things I've seen here and from the thrust of science and technology in this country that in our lifetime,
and I want to say when, but I imagine it's going to be a damn site sooner than anybody even here in this room can imagine,
they're going to be practical applications of some of these discoveries that have been made that will affect everyone of us.
And I think you're to be congratulated.
The other thing is that I get out of all this, that I think the United States ought to be spending two to three times.
The amount of money that we are spending on basic research and development and applied research and development.
And I think if you really look at the big picture of our energy requirements for clean energy in the future,
in order to improve the life of human beings on this planet, we ought to do that and get on with it.
Thank you.
During the next couple of months,
we'll probably have an opportunity to talk to a lot of people that help to have some influence or shape the pattern of our program and related programs.
And I would appreciate it very much and through we all could use the data.
As you find out things, we realize that you have preliminary data today and a lot of the things that are only hints and suggestions of things to come.
I would personally appreciate it very much if you give us a call periodically and tell us what you found.
It's too easy for us to go through here at the end of a week or so, walk off and never really know what happened and never know what kind of data came out.
And I think that makes us very poor salesman.
I think you could help us do the job to kind of feedback the quality of the data that you've been getting.
If you could keep us informed, please don't ever feel like you're interfering with our operation or don't be inhibited to call us.
If we can't come to the phone and take the data or talk to you about it,
the Secretary will take the number we'll be glad to call you back.
And if there's any time when you have some question about the data, it doesn't matter how trivial it may seem to you.
If you want to look at some data and you're curious to know whether we've ever seen a particular observation or whether the spacecraft was moving at the time,
your data was taken or I don't care how far out it might seem to you.
Questions are pretty cheap and not asking questions can be very expensive.
And so please feel like our job isn't finished until you guys have all information you can use.
And I would like for you to feel like you can call anytime.
Thank you very much.
I'd like to say, give you my thanks also.
I was very pleased with the way all the gear worked, especially my part on the lunar surface and part I saw of Ken and orbit.
It was just a real pleasure to have him placed all this stuff for all you people and glad it's working so well.
And thanks for the opportunity of going if you can gin up another one.
I'll be glad to go along again. Thank you.
Thank you.